OK, so today we've got a little
mathematical nugget for you.
I'm going to talk about
10 factorial.
So 10 factorial is what you
get when you multiply the
numbers 10 times 9
times 8 times 7--
and you go all the way down,
times 2, times 1.
How big is 10 factorial?
On your calculator you will find
a little bottom with an
exclamation mark after it.
There we go.
That is how big 10
factorial is.
Let's write this down.
3,628,800.
Now what I want to talk about
is 10 factorial seconds.
Now, how long is 10
factorial seconds?
All right, so 3,628,800
seconds.
How long is that?
Well, it turns out to be
exactly six weeks.
Let me show you.
We've got 10 factorial
seconds, so how
many minutes is that?
There are 60 seconds in
a minute, so I'm going
to divide by 60.
60 is 10 times 3 times 2.
That's the way I'm
going to do it.
So I'm going to divide by 60.
I can just cancel out
10 and 3 and 2.
That's a way to divide by 60.
I might as well cancel out the
1 as well, while I'm at it.
How many hours is that?
I'm going to divide
by 60 again.
Another way to write 60
is 5 times 4 times 3.
That also equals 60.
I'm going to cancel out
the 5 and the 4.
And I want to cancel 3.
I don't have it.
I'm going to take the
9, divide by 3.
So that now becomes
a 3 instead.
This is how many minutes
we've got.
How many hours is that?
I want to divide by 24.
24 is 8 times 3.
Divide by 8, and that
now disappears.
Fantastic.
24 is gone.
So this is how many
hours it is.
How many weeks is that?
There are seven days
in a week.
I want to divide by 7.
That's how many weeks it is.
How many weeks is it?
What's left?
Six.
There are exactly six weeks
for 10 factorial seconds.
Exactly.
So if you're at school, and if
you're looking forward to your
six weeks holiday, and oh, it
doesn't seem like long enough,
well, perhaps you might like
to think of it as your 10
factorial second holiday.
So let's try this from
the other direction.
So how many seconds are
there in six weeks?
So we've got six weeks.
How many days is that?
How many days are there
in six weeks?
We're going to times by 7.
Seven days a week.
How many hours is that?
24 hours in a day.
So we're going to times by 24.
How many minutes is that?
Well, let's times by 60.
60 minutes in an hour, and then
times by 60 again because
there's 60 seconds
in a minute.
This is how many seconds
you get in six weeks.
Now we get our calculator.
Let's see if we do get what
I said it was going to be.
6 weeks times 7 days times 24
hours times 60 minutes times
60 seconds is exactly
what I said before.
3,628,800, or to put it another
way, 10 factorial.